this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everybody to uh episode five
this year the cornell turf show
we got a golf golf show lined up for you
today uh maybe a little bit of masters
preview so we're excited about that
figure out figure we'll get ahead of uh
all the excitement next week um but as
always uh joined by dr frank rossi here
and
frank you've always got some thoughts
for us uh as we're
maybe are we maybe getting into the
growing season it's it's always a start
start and stop sort of uh
deal here but what are you thinking
these days can you see the slides carl
yep all right great sorry for that
trouble and and uh i'll do my little
thing carl i'll pass it for the minute
and then i'll you can take control of
the slides for your wonderful golf
presentation that you're going to give
it and of course
you know
again everybody's dealing with the with
the winter damage uh who had it i mean
everybody who's got this winter damage
that's what they're focused on we've had
a couple of shows about that i'm going
to refer to it a little bit but it's
it's be you know i hate to say it
because i'm sure i'm going to offend
somebody but it's beating a dead horse
you know we don't warm up this is going
to be a a tough go uh moving forward so
carl i always you know looking for a
cute dog picture at a cute kid picture
um you know we heard you when we were
chatting with somebody earlier today who
who who had who lost uh their dog
recently and and for those of us who've
had dogs over the years and golf courses
with dogs you always get new recruits
right so here here's a new recruit
getting ready finding their position
getting ready to start running so carl
why don't you start again taking us
through the bmp minute before i get to
the weather and some things to consider
for the week moving forward
yeah so so we love talking about this
project with our friends at the p2i
center and at the rit rochester
institute of technology uh so we're in
this step to this outreach and education
phase um so so for those listening who
don't know we're going to have a field
day april 6 next week out at saratoga
national
this is part of our
partnership with the gcsa ny
so we'll be out there talking about a
bunch of different things with
superintendent joe lucas that'll be i'm
sure a fascinating conversation maybe
some yelling and screaming who knows but
we're definitely going to talk about
bmps as well
so we're going to have our posters we're
going to have uh full-size posters out
there for
anybody attending so so come on over and
get a poster um a couple of things on
the poster that we're gonna talk about
today
uh knowing your nutrient needs so soil
testing mls and guidelines we've talked
about this in the past in spot treating
two ways you can really kind of dial in
optimize your fertilizer use or or pest
management
and a way you can do that better is to
use available data and one of the tools
i use which i really like is the web
soil survey so this is a free free tool
online
you can just go on your browser type it
in we have a tutorial that we posted on
youtube if you want to check that out
but there's a lot of great information
in here you can see the soil types on
your property
drainage class sand silk clay depth to
water table there's a ton of information
you can gain
and really what we see is this is this
is pretty accurate to what you'll
measure in the field so for those
watching in the top right uh there's a
electromagnetic
device that is used to basically predict
sand silt and clay
um
percentages in the soil and this was
done at locust hill many years ago with
with rick slattery when he was the
superintendent so he had a person come
out and use this device and map the
soils and you can see up there
on that top right of that that map is
dark dark brown that indicates kind of a
high clay content and to the bottom left
of that uh you see green which is more
of a sand content
um so that was a service he paid for and
got really good site specific data what
you'll see in the bottom right of this
screen is is the data straight from the
web soil survey so free online and while
it's not perfect it doesn't match up
perfectly with that other image that was
uh
ground truth data taken on the ground it
does pretty well right you see in the
top right there's this green shaded area
those are poorly drained soils and as
you move to the left and the lower part
of the property you see blue uh blue
soils those that end up being better
drained soil so it doesn't match up
great but it's it's a good approximation
and might help you target certain areas
certain fairways that you may want to
soil sample and treat differently
sorry carl i jumped the slides there too
quickly um
i will say
we're always looking for ways to get
easy data you know we're trying to you
know we i'm always yelling you got to be
more data driven uh but at the same time
we don't make it easy so i always
appreciate hearing about the easiest
easy ways to get data now let's look uh
where we're at this is what we're
expecting moving forward right this is
what we're expecting moving forward not
a lot of accumulation we heard from our
our weather guy rt guytano today and it
looks like we're heading into normal uh
conditions which is upper 40s and upper
50s you know we should be in the 60s
this time of year so we might we'll
we're going to have a difficult time at
least until wednesday
uh thursday of next week to start
getting any accumulation of heat now
looking back i mean again if you think
about the map i showed last week and
look at the map this week the colors
don't mean the same thing
red means warmer but it's everything is
below normal i mean you can even find
places
in the appalachians where they were 14
degrees below normal the norm i think
was between 6 to 8 degrees depending on
the way you looked at it across the
region
not as far below normal uh as you as you
get towards the coast now
this you know it again it when you look
at this data it's a little it's a little
counterintuitive this is still
indicating we're well ahead of normal
and i think it's easy to forget this uh
that we are still ahead of normal it was
a warm winter we had only a few really
cold months
um and so any little
progression of heat is really driving
the spring conditions really you know
very quickly so the spring leaf index
anomaly is indicating that up in the
northeast where they're measuring it
we're 20 days early
for things leafing out now you get to
other parts of the country there's a lot
of other cool regions in the country
that are not uh progressing as rapidly
now
the two in soil temperature i think is
where the discussion has to go if you
if you recall last week uh and even for
the last two weeks uh we were at almost
our low 50s for the two inch soil
temperature and just yesterday
this is looking like it's in the 30s and
40s at the two inch depth so obviously
that cold weather obviously the moisture
have had significant impacts on these
things so if you were you know putting
out your uh soil summer patch trench
early last week because you thought the
soil temperatures were going to keep
warming you know those things are just
sort of sitting there and we wonder how
long they last and getting on too early
is that going to make you have to make a
second application with some of your
root diseases we'll talk about this a
little bit more uh later in the spring
for sure uh just a couple of notes uh
matt elmore was noting that the
japanese still grass is starting to
emerge right so it used to be everything
was about crabgrass we're going to talk
about this obviously with the lawn and
grounds guys tomorrow used to be
everything was crabgrass you get your
stuff down for crabgrass right and now
we're thinking about goose grass that's
a little bit later and japanese steel
grass looks a little bit earlier than
crabgrass so if you have these shaded
areas this is a very strange plant that
is likely to cause us a lot of trouble
in the future for one big reason it's a
shade tolerant c4 grass
right it is a grass like crabgrass but
it does well in shaded conditions okay
well the conversation about
optimum timing for proxy primo seed head
suppression i think is upon us so
everybody i'm sure is considering
uh looking at this data and probably
throughout much of new york state in the
northeast have made their spring
application now i'm hoping many of you
who don't have injured turf uh put a
fall application down i'm still curious
and i haven't listened to some of the
banter that's been going on maybe bill
talked about this in his webinar with
the winter kill stuff but you know
is there any impact on the fall applied
proxy with damage is there any impact or
correlation with um how things are
recovering in the spring
and then what is the move for a seed
head suppression when you've got injured
poet because i would still say you need
to be in a growing stage not necessarily
in a uh
growth suppression state so anything
that's suppressing growth doesn't feel
right to me uh because you know i'd
rather have grass that had seed heads on
it uh that i could manage as a playing
surface than having no grass at all so
with that somebody posted uh their stock
of embarks which i thought was a nice
funny picture this person obviously has
stocked up over the years uh ready for
their embark and again embark's looking
pretty good uh along the metropolitan
new york area and again i think with
temperatures cold like they are
i wouldn't be surprised to see a little
bit of injury but i don't think this is
anything that's going to necessarily be
lethal so i mean if you're worried about
not doing this on uninjured turf because
it's a little cooler if the model says
it's good i'd rather do it i don't think
that
the injury is going to be severe and
there are ways of mitigating some of
these things with pigmented products as
well
now carl before i pass it off to you i
got a couple more things before we have
a golf conversation one is again some of
this very exciting work uh
florence sessoms is doing out at the
university of minnesota this is tall
fescue and ryegrass is part of this
winter injury work and this is what
they're calling a fall spring work so
you know their fall spring evaluation of
tall fescue and perennial rye grass so
what they do is uh they tend these areas
to get them to warm up right and then
expose them to cold temperature again
and so here is some of the original data
where you know there's no tenting this
has been in the greenhouse now there's
no tenting there's no warming up before
a cold period
so here is a day of fall spring really
warmed up with back to cold temperatures
in the middle and you can see some of
the tall fescue injured and then of
course you get the five days of fall
spring where you're getting warming
conditions and you see the tall fescues
injured even more now this is really
corollary to what i showed the last
couple of weeks about how annual
bluegrass will break dormancy in the
spring how will break dormancy under
warm wet conditions right those crown
hydration conditions so we're starting
to see i believe a lot of what is
ultimately going to explain some of the
damage that we're seeing that these
systems have just warmed up the dormancy
breaks
cold temperatures return and you see
some damage associated with those cold
temperatures so now the question is and
everybody's talking about this uh is the
time you know can we be seeding and
we're starting to see this happens to be
uh some kentucky bluegrass seed starting
to pop and i thought it was really
interesting zack ryker was talking about
some seating work he's done in the past
and you can see this is from 30 years
ago when he was an extension agent and
doing early extension work at purdue
this is indicating at least with things
like bluegrass tall fescue and ryegrass
that earlier seedings tend to have a
little bit more success than waiting
right now kentucky bluegrass is a little
bit different than creeping bankrass and
a little bit different of course than
annual bluegrass
where because it takes so long to
germinate right you're looking at a very
long germination period 20 days
to get it popped so i think it's
important to consider if you've got
damaged greens it's time to get in there
start prepping those seed beds it looks
like the weather's going to start
getting on our side and it looks like
the sooner you get after this the better
off you're going to be
nothing's going to happen until we start
to get uh warm temperatures but for sure
uh we want to start getting at the
seating now now carl as i pass it to you
i will say that historically there
hasn't been a lot of information shared
about augusta national and you're going
to tell us not this week because they're
in texas this week but next week when we
meet they'll be underway at the masters
and i thought it was interesting they
built underground tunnels uh on the
property to be able to move things
around underneath the people uh so i
think carl as i pass it to you i'm
really fascinated to see uh what you're
gonna share with us to get everybody
excited about the masters this year
because as you bring your slides up i'll
tell you this is one of those times of
the year where golfers watch it on tv
and then they go out and they're like
how come i don't have this or the open
happens right in june and it's like how
come our golf course doesn't look like
this so i know you're gonna take us
through uh number one what augusta does
and number two how bad uh normal golfers
are compared to really good golfers
which of course you're among the ranks
so thanks for taking us through this
yeah thanks frank um
i i think you're exactly right and what
we see on tv isn't what we as as average
golfers probably want or need in our
golf experience um but really up here in
the northeast as i've grown in my early
childhood childhood and now yeah young
adulthood
the masters really represents the kind
of the beginning of spring golf and i
think for a lot of us northeastern
golfers we're stuck in the snow and the
cold
and we hear the piano sound and we see
the green grass and they tell us we are
invited to watch the masters it's it's
go time for spring golf uh so one of my
favorite things is watching the on the
range coverage now you can watch so many
parts of augusta national
um but but the other thing i i think is
synonymous with augusta national is the
just kind of the pinnacle of agronomy
right we see the green speeds um i was
looking around trying to find some
agronomic data okay is there anything
little tidbits out there that that give
us an insight into how they manage um
there are published uh turf mowing
heights um
you know pretty pretty standard it says
the greens here are cut at 125. uh maybe
i don't believe that so much hi
that's high that's these these are again
just recorded um but when we watch we
can see the green speeds are fast and
that's kind of a calling card of augusta
national
um but one of the interesting things i i
found some people who apparently have
knowledge of the situation
they purposely manage their green speeds
on different greens two different
standards
uh and the thinking behind that is and
we've seen this in action at major
championships frank uh people setting up
the golf course have an intuitive feel
of how that green should play given
these slopes and the architecture
so what i imagine is going on at augusta
is certain greens that have a lot of
slope and they want balls to use that
slope and finish in certain areas they
probably keep those greens a little bit
slower maybe on the 12 foot side for
augusta national whereas some of the
flatter greens bigger greens probably
are a little bit faster
and the idea there is trying to get all
these greens to feel quote unquote feel
the same speed for for the players
playing them obviously a lot of the golf
courses that if you're listening and you
have a golf course that's probably not
feasible to maintain every green to a
certain standard like that
but that sort of site specific idea is
what we want to get people moving
towards
um but maybe more one of the more
noticeable things uh is the way they mow
these fairways in the background here
you see about 10 fairway mowers
going after it all in one direction all
towards the green
you'll hear announcers talk about how
this slows the golf ball down it reduces
the distances the pros can hit it
so i was interested you know is there
any data on that it turns out there is
buried in the usga distance report
everybody's busy yelling about if the
ball goes too far or not there's some
really cool data buried in that report
from pga tour sites looking at mowing
with or against the grain and how that
affects roll-out
and it's really not that much it's
between three to ten yards it depends on
turf species
zoysia there's a bigger effect than
poenua or perennial ryegrass which is
the grass you'll see the masters so this
is probably more of a soil moisture
effect on the rollout that you'll see at
augusta national
um but mowing into the grain from the
from the green to the tea
what you'll hear the players talk about
is
uh the the iron play and that requires a
lot more
um
consistency accuracy in the strike
there's not enough there's not as much
margin for error when you're getting
into the grain we know this chipping
into bermuda grain if you've ever done
that that is a very highly skilled
technique
um and so what you see at the masters is
you always see the best iron players
excel at augusta and
probably a part of that is these
fairways being mowed into them the whole
way
sergio garcia's tiger woods have always
done well the masters you'll probably
see if you're looking for my picks
cameron smith russell henley
tom hoagy is a name you probably don't
know but those guys are really good iron
players and i would guess probably do
well at augusta
and then you know one little thing of of
course augusta has their own kinds of
mowers you'll see the quote here they
developed a mower um
that basically has one side lower than
the other and they run this right on the
edge of the green edge and the collar
edge
and this helps smooth out the transition
from the green to the collar
so again a very little detail and really
it's kind of that pinnacle agronomy um
that we all look at on tv in the spring
and up here in our northern brains are
like oh man that's be so good
uh why don't i get out there on the golf
course
um so we use we use some data from the
paluzi corporation um that tells us
during any day of the year what would
the expected rounds number be based on
the weather you're given so if it's a
nice sunny day you can do a lot of
rounds
um and when we look at this data on the
left we see in the spring months right
march april and may there's a ton of
variability in
the amount of rounds we can do capacity
is what we call it
given the weather right so we can do as
much as 170 more than average or
almost uh 100 less than average right so
there's huge variability in our spring
season and this again revolves around
this april date and the masters and
people getting momentum going out to the
golf course
uh it's important to know that that that
generates momentum from your golfers in
the northeast but the weather is really
going to drive what you can actually do
with that momentum on the right side of
the screen you see summer months june
and july a lot less variability in what
we can do so for our daily fee golf
courses who can really make a lot of
their revenue in the shoulders of the
season
the weather is going to drive all this
all that early season revenue
and unfortunately we have been dealt a
poor hand this year um so again we're
beating a dead horse here you can see on
the screen winter injury damage right
uh that's been a big concern that
requires
uh recovery it requires keeping golfers
off of these areas that's not a good
thing if you're trying to get spring
golf
um we've been on a temperature roller
coaster ride here i've got some data on
the bottom of the screen
where you can really see how we've been
outside of our normal range this brown
range we spent a lot of time in march
outside of that range whether it's been
above or below most recently below
none of which bodes well for getting our
golf courses prepped for golfers here in
the spring
and just uh you know see where we were
on our playability in our our turf bots
went out yesterday
uh we're stimping at a cool six feet
nine inches uh we're not super smooth
either we're six out of ten on the
bopple test
um so again this is really going towards
hey we're seeing augusta on tv but
our golfers out here should not be
expecting golf course conditions uh like
augusta national um so of course a long
i've got some data here pros versus
joe's right the pros are playing a 7 400
yard golf course they're hitting at 290
yards they hit about 10 greens per round
our average golfers are playing a maybe
a 6100 yard course it actually should be
shorter
they hit about 210 yards and they barely
hit five or six screens around so
really what they need and what they
should be looking for out of a golf
experience is probably not what's on
television
um so so what do they want and and i've
been interested in this for a while have
we surveyed golfers and on what they
want and it turns out some folks in
europe have a couple studies one here
from myers co college
and the university of copenhagen
so asking kind of about green speed hey
how important is green speed
uh so in this myers coast study about 70
percent of folks said that green speed
is important
and that makes sense right people people
golfers generally like faster greens
but they also post the same question
about smoothness okay do smooth greens
make a difference
in your golf experience and over 90
of golfers indicated that smoothness was
very important or important so
smoothness is really king when you're
looking at speed versus smoothness
same thing was found in this
study as part of the scandinavian
turfgrass research foundation
about 75 percent of people said even
role was a large factor in their
experience
only 35 percent of people said this
green speed is a large factor
right and and the other thing when you
look at this data is its age and ability
dependent
so uh younger and lower handicap players
they're going to put more emphasis on
green speed the older and
higher handicap players care more about
the evenness of roll
we see a similar thing in fairway lies
so they asked do you want the ball to be
carried by the grass kind of teed up
cushioned or would you like it to lie
close to the ground
again we see a age response here with
predominantly people saying they want
the ball carried by the grass at augusta
national you're going to see the ball
very tight to the surface and that's
what the pros like that's what the high
the uh the low handicap golfers like
but generally average golfers older
golfers they like a little bit of tea a
little bit of forgiveness
when you're creating a fairway lie
and then when you just look at things
not even uh golf condition related um
good company right that's the number one
thing they said is
central to their enjoyment of the game
of golf good company
good weather
pace of play right those are the top
three things uh green speed came in
fifth here so
what i'm trying to underline here is is
when people are getting out onto your
golf course after seeing the masters
this week
um it's not about green speed it's not
about that elite conditioning it's about
being outside when it's 45 degrees and
sunny it's about spending time with with
friends and family
trying to play a game of golf in a
reasonable amount of time
um now this is this can be specific to
your region so all that data is from
from europe
uh if we're thinking about our u.s
golfer they probably have a different
mindset
and even within new york there's
probably a different mindset so again
this is data from the polluted
corporation
that we use for our state park golf
courses
down in long island about 65 of the
surrounding
clubs around bethpage state park are
private
when you look at syracuse a lot of the
golf courses
most of them are public and there's a
pretty even distribution between uh kind
of high price point public and low price
point public
so so your golfer and what i'm trying to
get at here is what do your golfers want
you know how old are they what sort of
playing ability are they um have you
noticed trends change and i think frank
you and i have noticed uh trends and
and the people we're seeing on golf
courses have changed
so i think all this should be considered
into how you manage the golf course
especially coming out out here in the
spring and
where i want to transition the
conversation frank is should clubs be
surveying their members on what they
like in a golf course experience and how
would that relate to them establishing
uh sort of maintenance standards we see
that the peak of maintenance standards
at augusta
how can we use maybe club survey data to
establish these sort of standards for
our own golf courses
i tell you carl this is wonderful the
first couple of things i'd start with is
the following
how much of this matters when
people aren't actually playing the golf
course correctly a couple of things come
to mind i looked at the distance report
from a couple years ago and one of the
things that jumped out at me they had
this wonderful timeline of how the game
has progressed since hollow
drivers through you know all the way
through uh changing the grooves
and and one of the things that uh you
notice is to your point the corn fairy
tour kids hit it further than the pros
the pga tour guys so the young guys are
already bombing it past the big guy so
distance is going to continue to be an
issue when you said i thought it was you
know you sort of went through it but
a tour pro hits on average 10 greens in
regulation per round
you're saying uh a
regular golfer hits five greens but
they're not hitting those greens from
the same distance in other words the
five green hit is from what
120 yards how far is that it's it's well
they're still playing courses that are
longer than they should be playing so
from 6 100 yards uh you know the average
golfers may be hitting a 170 160 yard
approach but for them that's a five iron
and when you look at pga tour stats
very rarely are pros hitting five irons
into par fours
um so so part of them and maybe what a
superintendent can do especially early
in the season when golfers are getting
their legs under them move the t's up
move the t's up
really the usga says average golfers
should be
playing from about 5700 yards at a lot
of courses that's the forward tees
i don't like calling them ladies tees i
like calling them forward tees because
a lot of people should be playing them
not just ladies it's really about um
playing a course that's going to give
you
a couple wedges into par floors around a
couple nine irons very rarely do i see
average golfers having short irons in
because they're playing too long yeah um
so so to your point frank the core setup
and maybe trying to get some more
firmness in the fairways trying to get
some more roll out get them closer to
the green
those sorts of things can make the
experience better for the average golfer
because it's going to make it easier and
that's right and there's a saying if
you're making too many birdies and
you're having too much fun you can you
can play longer tees
and people very rarely do that once they
figure out they can have a lot of fun
from forward t's
it makes the experience a lot better and
i you know the other thing i think carl
that's worth mentioning as we you know
wrap up around the the confluence of you
know you've got injured grass or it's a
slow spring
and they're watching you know golf in in
southern california or golf and georgia
and i think it's really important to
understand that our golf courses up here
from a data perspective of what we would
consider to be peak conditioning
is months from now
it's literally months it's literally
months from now so you know there's a
certain amount that every golf course
superintendent should be doing in the
spring to you know get the grass in
shape get good turf cover get the place
uh looking sharp and detailed up and
then
slowly start to shift to uh you know
playing performance and maximizing and
getting to that peak performance and and
one of the things we know with daniel
bluegrass is you can actually get it
going pretty good in the spring under
really good conditions it really doesn't
struggle very much when the weather is
on your side
bent grass is going to have a little bit
more trouble right it's going to be
slower to wake up so i think it's really
important when everybody approaches you
on a first tee to practice green and
you're having this conversation hey how
about augusta it's like yeah man i can't
wait to i would just say i can't wait
till we're at peak performance right
because they're turning on a tv carl
every week and that's the peak
conditioning you know you talked last
week about how chris tritibal at
hazeltine uses those metrics for
determining when he's where he wants to
be
and i think we need to be realistic with
our golfers that
unless they're spending tons of money
it's hard to get the peak performance
april first yeah you know what i mean
and especially with this winter injury
stuff frank and we got some comments
from blake uh talking about how covers
have been very useful for him even in
the last week when we haven't had ideas
air temperatures
um the other thing he's saying is is he
got he has some areas uh of poe where
there may be kind of coming back now
should he core aerate those
uh and try and push uh regrow through
that or if he's seeing some of that come
up should he just let that ride and try
and grow what's what's coming back up
yeah you know that's a great question
and the answer to me is is is really
it's a bit of a guess you got to figure
out if i if i start to get the weather
on my side will the plants i see there
uh fill in effectively if we don't think
they will and my guess is they won't
because you know these early plants are
very killer oriented they're not going
to start producing lateral growth and
start pegging in like a like a stolen
inference grass or a more perennial type
i i think right now it's going to be
critical to do what you can to get early
you know as early cover quick cover as
you can and annual bluegrass thrives it
thrives in disturbance and it will get
from a seed
to a few tillers in a couple of weeks so
i think based on what zack is showing in
that data for other grasses we're best
even with grass coming up unless it's
pretty tight already to to bust it up
create a seed bed and get it going yeah
great question thanks this is great
stuff carl get us out of here yep i
think uh what i'll say you know you're
talking about peak performance frank if
if a golfer comes up to you this can be
a line you can use if your
superintendent here in the northeast
coming up the golfer says hey why aren't
the greens better uh you can say hey why
aren't you are in peak condition right
now i just saw you hit that iron shot
and it wasn't very good you're not
either so well that's why you and i
aren't golf course superintendents carl
because that is the exact thing you
don't say to those people so maybe
that'll that'll be so yeah don't say
that say it under your breath maybe um
but uh thanks everybody for watching
today's show a little master's preview
for you guys i will be back tomorrow
with the lawn and landscape show we're
going to be talking to uh dr carl
guillard of uconn he's got some really
interesting soil testing uh research
he'll talk about tomorrow a regional
mlsn project for those who know what
that is so
tune in for that
but for now thank you take care and
see in a bit
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu